I just wanted to say that we've all made
terrible decisions but this will be a
good one and I'm so honored to be here
celebrating this beautiful couple so
everybody let's raise a glass to love
laughter and welcoming a new baby into
this world
I'm so sorry Cheers
yeah because she gave you the one part
that's gained weight for her wedding
right I mean she's already showing
totally oh yeah I was really bad and I'm
like kind of attracted to you right now
okay okay it wasn't as bad as our
wedding ceremony remember that was the
best I had personally had a great time I
really I loved it good I wept through
our honeymoon
Lucy I will love you honor you cherish
you I will you are my inspiration to
stay in shape and we will go to the gym
get our memberships together I kind of
didn't remember I'm still in therapy
you're in therapy for a million other
reasons can we not do this year the time
Milo had a little jaunt down romance
Lane are you talking about what I think
you're talking about
come on Milo Milo fine okay I'm getting
married hey Milo you have to go put it
on it's tradition we're let's do it
that guy was a stud such a stud
remember the farm fiasco that was insane
love it well that sort of won't be back
for at least an hour come on take the
picture come on come on he's peeing on
your dress watch this enough why oh my
gosh okay please stop it those stupid
chickens big chicken oh really
okay your broccoli I'll take tank tank
tank tank Mike hi y'all I'm Jeff Bryan's
good friend from college before I
congratulate the happy couple over here
I just wanted to tell all y'all about
this crowd start a fund raiser I just
launched its what a graphic novel
I just wrote called the blood oath of
the wrath I do not feel so bad anymore I
think you're in the clear oh yeah do you
think he's single these
basketball-playing vampires they bite
rubber does the best not date that guy
compromising your grandma's loving it
okay let me Ted this is this parts for
you you're gonna love this all right so